-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
You're here.
You made it. You're watching.
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys, last night,
President Biden announced
new vaccine mandates that could
apply to 100 million Americans
and he told the unvaccinated
that his patience
is wearing thin.
Yeah. Apparently,
Biden's new speechwriter
used to be
a substitute teacher.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, my patience
is running thin.
You want me
to continue this movie?"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Biden says his patience
is wearing thin.
Asked how thin, Biden said,
"Somewhere between paper
and the new Kim Jong-un.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Biden outlined his plan
to boost vaccinations
among federal workers
and private employees.
And, if that doesn't work,
he's just going
to slip the vaccine
in every pumpkin spice latte,
[ Laughter ]
so I think that'll work.
[ Applause ]
That's a good idea.
Speaking of vaccines --
today, Moderna said
they're working
on a single shot that's a COVID
booster and a flu shot.
[ Murmuring ]
Americans heard and were like,
"Throw in some dewormer,
and you got yourself a deal.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, we'll talk."
That's right,
COVID vaccine-flu shot combo.
Not to be outdone,
Johnson & Johnson
just released their...
[ Laughter and applause ]
No tears.
Some sports news --
last night was
the first NFL game of the year
and the Buccaneers
beat the Cowboys
on a last-second field goal.
Did you guys watch that?
[ Brief cheer,
smattering of applause ]
Over 20 million people
watched last night's game.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
Lisa, from Blackpink,
heard that and was like,
"20 million views?
That's so cute."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some business news --
I saw that Peloton just debuted
its first-ever line of apparel.
Now, when Peloton people see
Lululemon people in the streets,
it's going to be like
"West Side Story."
[ Laughter ]
[ Snaps fingers ]
[ The Roots playing jazz ]
I'm excited for the new line
because,
after you wear the clothes,
you can just hang them
on the Peloton you never use.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Get this -- I read that
the trucking industry is divided
over whether to let teenagers
become interstate truck drivers.
[ Laughter ]
It's kind of strange.
Somehow, an 18-year-old
could drive
an 80,000-pound truck,
but has to wait
seven more years
to rent a Toyota Corolla.
Don't you think?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
This is exciting, though --
I heard, this next year,
a live "Bridgerton" experience
is coming to cities
around the world.
Fans were like,
[ Sultry tone ]
"What kind of live experience?
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa.
-And, finally,
a new survey found
that almost half of shoppers
put healthy items in their cart
just to avoid judgment
at the register.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, apparently customers
check out with the grapefruit,
then tell the cashier,
"My car's out back.
Bring the Bagel Bites."
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen.
-♪ Mesmerizing ♪
♪ State-of-the-art caffeine ♪
♪ Over your head
like "Omniverse" screen ♪
♪ Not the average savage
that curse queens ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm
from his worst dreams ♪
♪ The first we handling ♪
♪ First things ♪
♪ Subsurface 215, yeah ♪
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-What a big show tonight!
Big show tonight!
Lisa is here.
Oh, my goodness!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Big show. I want to get
into everyone who's on the show,
but just a heads-up.
This is exciting for us --
all next week,
it's going to be Broadway week
here at "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh.
-I'm excited.
We are celebrating the return
of Broadway every single night.
Ready for these performances?
Every night's a different
live performance here
in the studio.
Monday,
"Little Shop of Horrors."
[ Cheering and applause ]
Tuesday, "Tina,"
the Tina Turner --
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Ooh.
-And I think, maybe,
Tina's going to do
"Private Dancer."
-Whoa.
-I don't know.
-Ooh.
-I know.
I was thinking
about which one would --
I mean, you can't really request
a Broadway cast to do a song,
but --
-But, if you're going
to request...
-If you're gonna,
"Private Dancer's" my jam.
My mom used to lip-sync
that song.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-When we were kids.
I don't know if she knew
what she was lip-syncing.
-Yeah, I was like, "Word?
-I don't think she did.
-Really?"
-We would have, you know,
things that we would do,
skits and stuff and everyone
sing songs at the house.
And you know, she you do
"You Don't Bring Me Flowers"
to my dad and, you know,
we would throw like fake roses
at her at the end and stuff.
And then,
she did a whole like --
♪ I'm your private dancer ♪
♪ A dancer for money ♪
And we're like --
♪ Do anything ♪
And you go, "Whoa, whoa, whoa."
Now I'm older, yeah, I never --
[ Laughter ]
She would sing
"Private Dancer."
-Now, it's problematic.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Now it's yeah, exactly.
That would be bad.
What's the other Tina jams?
-"Better Be Good to Me."
-Oh, man.
-Oh!
♪ Better be good to me ♪
Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Scat singing ]
What's another good jam?
-"Proud Mary."
-"Hero."
-"What's Love Got to Do
with It" and "Hero."
"Hero's" the jam.
-That's a good one.
-"What's Love Got to Do
with It."
-Oh, that's my -- Oh, yeah.
No, no, no.
That was the jam.
♪ What's love ♪
With the chain link fence.
♪ Got to do with it? ♪
Oh, it's a good jam.
Anyway, one of those jams.
-One of them.
-Yeah. I'm hoping it's
"Private Dancer."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But you never know.
Wednesday night --
We're only on --
That was only Tuesday.
-What?!
-The week gets better
and better.
Maybe not.
I mean, they're all equally --
[ Laughter ]
But, Wednesday,
"Dear Evan Hansen."
-Oh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah.
Thursday,
"Six" is going to be here.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Friday, closing it out...
[ Cluck ]
"Wicked."
-Oh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
I don't know what to do anymore.
It's just amazing.
-That's it.
-And it's all here
in the studio.
It's going to be great.
Broadway Week -
Broadway every single night,
so tune in next week.
Set your DVRs, your TiVos,
whatever you do.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
Whatever you do to record...
-...because you're going
to want to rewatch these.
-Yeah, rewatch it
24 hours a day,
7 days a week.
-Yeah. What do you do, VHS?
-I do Betamax.
[ Laughter ]
-No. You still do that.
-Yeah.
-Hook up to a Maxell cassette.
-Exactly.
So then, it runs into cassette
and then, I play it on one
of those Fisher-Price things.
-And then you have to time --
you have to time
the audio to that
and it comes
through a Teddy Ruxpin doll.
-Exactly. That's the only
way I can hear it.
And then, usually, I'll tape --
-I think it's cool.
People think it's weird
to see you on the subway
with a Teddy bear singing,
like --
♪ I'm your private dancer ♪
That's what Teddy Ruxpin's for.
-Why, you know?
-Yeah, what's the problem?
-Ruxpin it up.
-"Don't judge me, man."
[ Laughter ]
But, first, let's get
into our show tonight.
What a show we have tonight.
You can see her
in "The Morning Show."
Gosh, I love her.
It's back for its second season
on Apple TV+.
Reese Witherspoon
is joining us.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Drumming] Hey!
-Come on.
-I'm a big fan.
Plus, he stars in the biggest
movie in the world right now.
From Marvel's "Shang-Chi and the
Legend of the Ten Rings,"
Simu Liu is here!
-Oh!
[ Boisterous cheering
and applause ]
-The biggest movie.
-In the world.
-Crushed! Crushed!
I love that dude.
Simu Liu.
And she just released a video
for her new song, "La Lisa,"
and, within 12 hours,
it was already viewed
over 50 million times
on YouTube.
We've got a performance
from Lisa tonight!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah.
It's a good jam, too.
You want to hear a little bit
of Lisa?
Here's "Lalisa," right here.
Ready?
Listen to this jam.
-♪ Say, Lalisa ♪
♪ Love me, Lalisa,
love me, hey! ♪
♪ Hold me, Lalisa,
love me, La-- ♪
Come on.
That's a jam, right there.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about.
Oh, and later in the show,
we have an all-new
"Thank You Notes,"
so stay tuned
for later in the show,
[ Cheering and applause ]
when we come back
from commercial.
But, first,
guys, the latest Apple launch
event is just four days away
and a lot of people
are speculating
about what new products
the company will
and will not be announcing.
So with that in mind, it's time
for "Fact vs. Fiction."
Here we go.
-♪ Fact ♪
♪ "Fact vs. Fiction" ♪
-Let's get started.
First, fact...
Fiction...
[ Cheering and applause ]
Just keep...
Next up, fact...
-Ooh.
-Fiction...
[ Cheering and applause ]
You get one at a time.
After that, we have fact...
Fiction...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Just to really point out --
Just to really point out
who's different, yeah.
Next, there's fact...
-Ooh.
-Fiction...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-'Sup?
-Yeah.
-#something.
-Next, there's fact...
-Oh.
-Fiction...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Can't be in this universe.
And, finally, fact...
Fiction...
There you go.
That's all the time
we have
for "Fact vs. Fiction."